and to the light of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and to the
to the
worship of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and a person's heart
becoming open and softened by
these things. this chapter
as we've noticed, we've been
going through it for probably a
couple of months and the reason
for that, maybe even 3 months
or so and the reason for that
is the importance of this
chapter. This chapter is
actually of such significance
that some scholars of Islam
after the The writing of this
book have actually taken this
chapter alone which is kind of
a brief chapter. It's only a
few pages really long in this
in the larger scheme of and
they have explained it and
elaborated on it and made it
into it's an independent book.
Due to its importance. this
chapter largely is a summary of
many of things that Allah
mentions in one of his other
more prestigious books which is
is a book all about the worship
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
We mentioned that Tawheed is
two types. There is Tawhid,
Arububia, Uluhiya, Al Tawhid,
Al Ali Mul Marifa, Watheed, Al
Halas
these two types of or the of of
knowledge and and and
understanding and belief in
Allah and Tawheed with regards
to worship of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala and sincerity to
Allah. Those are traditionally
the two categories of Tawheed
that the scholars have
mentioned. This categorization
is not something which is open
to debate. It's not something
that is open to addition or
subtraction. Actually, this is
what is taken from the Quran
and Sunnah with what is
regarding with what is referred
to amongst the scholars of as
the Quran is a type of evidence
in Islamic jurisprudence. What
is a well is the Quran? A Quran
is when a major scholar who has
read, memorized embodied,
understood, the entirety of the
Quran and as much of the that
he was able to get his hands on
And this scholar becomes so
proficient and so conscious of
the Quran and Sunnah and have
has immersed himself in the
Quran in Sunnah so much that he
is able to see patterns in the
Quran and that are not
otherwise that are not not
otherwise apparent to someone
of lesser investigation So,
they will look at the Quran and
Sunnah as if it's one image. If
it's as if it's one, one unit
and they are able to see the
patterns that are in it and so
from those patterns, they are
able to derive principles. And
these are what are called
referred to by some scholars as
the main focal points and
fulcrums of legislation. The
main reasoning behind all of
the legislation of Islam,
right? And so, of these, this
is what is called a Quran. When
a scholar mentions a ruling
that is not necessarily
specifically mentioned in the
Quran or in the sunnah
categorically as a hadith or as
a verse but they notice this
pattern throughout and this
thread all the way through the
Quran and Sunnah. They can come
to a conclusion through a that
this is something that has not
been explicitly stated but is
implied all the way through the
Quran and Sunnah and it's a
pattern which fits all of the
Quran the sunnah. Now, through
this, there are the categories
of Tawhid for for instance. The
categories of Tawhid
traditionally are either two or
three categories and the most
well-known and most worked on
by the scholars and built upon
are two categories of Tawhit
which what we mentioned, Toheed
the and Toheed al Uluhiya. The
be as we mentioned before at
the beginning of this journey
through this chapter is the
oneness of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala with regards to
everything having to do with
Allah. Meaning affirming and
believing in his names, his
attributes, his actions, his
descriptions, his judgement,
everything having to do with
Allah and what we know about
him and what we affirm and
believe in. The second category
of Tawheed is which is worship,
the Tawheed of worship. And
that is affirming and making
sincerely and only for Allah
all forms of our worship. That
that's regarding our actions,
right? So, some scholars have
simplified it and said, the
B, Bima, yes, the
[Silence]
He's the only creator. He's the
only one that has
ownership of all of the
creation. He is the one who has
complete discretion and he is
the only one that maintains
that creation and keeps that
creation in existence, right?
Which is an important point
that he keeps that creation in
existence. So, Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala did not just create
us and we are independently
kept in existence. We are kept
in existence and the laws of
nature as we know them and the
laws of physics and my
existence and your existence
and the heavens and the earth
and everything else are
constantly at every single
moment being kept in existence
actively by Allah. So, we are
not independent in any way of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's, of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's
maintenance of this creation.
The second category is which is
our devotion and our worship of
Allah alone without any
partners which means our
actions now. That We know Allah
and we worship Allah and we
make sincere to him all forms
of worship and we consider
worship only that which Allah
considers worship and anything
else, we consider to be
innovation, right? This is
Tawheed, Tawhid, El Uluhiya and
this roots back all the way
back to even Abes, this
categorization and it also
mentioned in three categories
by and his as and
the Tawheed of the names and
attributes of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala as a third category
but really that third category
actually fits into the first
and so the most popular amongst
the scholars of Islam has been
has been that categorization,
two categories of Tawhite.
wrote an independent book on
each of these types of Tawhid.
Of course, he mentions all
throughout his works, these
types of Tawheed and most of
his works revolve around the
Tawheed of Allah and the
correct belief of the Muslims.
However, most specifically in
he wrote his book It's a very
lengthy book on all about Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. And it's a
very important book for those
who read Arabic to read. There
are some philosophical debates
and some logic reputations and
so forth that Ibnil Kaim does.
It's a very lengthy book. But
there are summarizations of it.
And a bridge versions. And it's
a book that is invaluable to
the Muslim library. The second
that he wrote is essentially an
in-depth explanation, a very
in-depth explanation of all of
the stages that a person goes
through in their worship of
Allah and that is considered
his most prominent work on the
subject of Tawheed Al Uluhiya.
This chapter that we are
discussing here which is the
chapter of the causes for the
heart to become open and to
become receptive to the Quran
and Sunnah and to the light of
Allah This is mainly kind of a
of a lot of what mentions in
his book Madera just is a life
changing book. I, I, my story
with the book, Madera
Giseliquin, goes back probably
about 13 years ago. When I
first I purchased it before
that, but didn't really know
what I was purchasing. And when
I had begin to read my daddie
Giuseli Kian and I read through
it and read the depth of it. It
is absolutely life changing. A
person will read that book and
never see the world again the
same way. Due to the depth that
goes into with regards to the
heart and its actions and its
beliefs and its and so forth.
He goes through different
things a with and reliance
upon Allah and trust in Allah
and belief in Allah and
repentance and thankfulness and
so forth. It's a very in-depth
book on the worship of Allah.
This chapter really kind of
catches the essence of in a
very summarized way because
obviously that's not the that's
not topic or subject of this
book The final point that we're
going to mention tonight is
very important and I'm going to
approach it in a way that will
be very practical for us.
next week inshallah, we will
move on to the prophet with
regards to fasting. How he used
to fast. Some of the things
regarding fasting, some of the
rulings of fasting, etcetera.
The mention which is kind of
appropriate because we're about
two and a half months out from
Ramadan. So it kind of fits.
but tonight, inshallah, we're
going to be speaking about the
tenth and final point that he
makes. The first point, just a
review, a recap of the points
that he made. Number one, he
mentions one of the greatest
and the greatest cause for the
heart to be open and receptive
to the light of Allah. we make
our hearts open we open our
hearts, what we're essentially
doing is we are opening our
hearts as a as a as an open
slate for Allah to wipe from
it, whatever he desires, and
write on it, whatever he
desires. Subhanahu wa ta'ala,
right? This is the meaning of
so when we see that the literal
in Shirah have a is to
literally open up the chest and
open the heart and this
happened literally to the
prophet two times in his life.
First, when he was a young
child playing with the children
under the watch of Halima
Sadiya, and then the second
time, in he mentions in the
narration of Abidar in the
Sahih that while he was
sleeping, the roof of the home
was removed and
descended with a golden bowl
and it had water of Zemzem in
it and he opened the prophet
chest and took out his heart
and removed a clot of blood and
he said to him this is the
portion of a Shaitan that he
has as leverage over you. It is
now being removed. And then he
washed his heart in that golden
basin or that golden bowl of
Zemzem and then he returned it
into his chest. He said and
then filled my chest with with
wisdom and knowledge. This is
what the prophet said. This is
not metaphorical. This actually
happened physically. Now, Enes,
later mentions that he saw
because Ennis was the prophet
servant. When the prophet made
Hijra to Madinah, which is
Anas's mother, mother, she met
the prophet and Anas was 10
years old. And she said, this
is my son. I offer him to you
as a servant. Let him be your,
your servant. He has no other
work to do. No chores, nothing
is expected of him from us.
Except that he be your
servants. So, he served the
prophet from 10 years old to 20
years old when the prophet
passed away. Now, being that he
would was at such a young age,
we have a lot of insights into
the private life of the prophet
Gazenis was there and he seen
the prophet without his shirt
on. He's he's told us about the
seal of prophethood in his back
and he also said that I saw the
stitch marks in his chest from
when his chest was open. So,
this is a physical thing. How
did it happen? How can you take
someone's heart out while
they're living? This is, this
is not our business. This is
something supernatural, right?
This is this is not something
that is is regulated by the
laws of physics as we know it.
This is a miracle from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. So, he
mentions that the greatest of
these things is a Tawhid which
we went into and it's different
and it's different categories
and we also discussed its
opposites. The the next he
mentions is
light both physical and
metaphorical light of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. The more
exposure a person has to the
light of Allah and physical
light. The more a person will
become prone to accepting the
guidance of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. What do you mean
physical light? We just mention
now that opening the chest for
the prophet happened both
physically and metaphorically,
correct? And the same thing
goes for us. Our body carries
the carries the soul and the
only way that we can get to the
soul is through the body.
Right? And the hereafter it
will be the opposite. The soul
will be primary and the body
will be derivative. But here
this life, the only way we get
to the soul is through the
body. This is why we make wudu,
right? I mean, what is wudu? Is
it is it to clean the actual
physical body? in a way but
really it's a spiritual
cleansing, right? It's
something that affects the soul
and so, physical lights,
exposure to physical lights,
being awake in the morning when
the sun rise, going to sleep,
when the sun goes, when the sun
sets, etcetera. This is in line
with the heart being becoming
more in line with the fitra of
Allah. wa ta'ala. Likewise and
Mohammed the third thing is
knowledge which has been passed
down from the prophet and it is
what is referred to as
beneficial knowledge. The
fourth
the fourth is turning
completely to Allah. Opening
yourself up and making yourself
totally vulnerable to Allah and
loving him with the entirety of
your heart. And we discuss that
in in detail. He says the fifth
thing, the
this the fifth thing to
consistently, constantly,
always remember Allah in every
state of being and in every
place you find yourself. In
every state of being, in every
state you find yourself. To
remember Allah in the night, in
the day, in work, in the
masjid, alone, with people,
remember him with your heart,
remember him with your tongue.
Mention him speak of him, speak
about him, Tell others about
him. Have discussions about
him. When's the last time you
sat in a gathering where Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala was the
topic of that gathering?
Seriously, think about it.
some sometimes it's almost to
the point where we are kind of
ashamed to sit in a gathering
and make it into a religious
thing. You know, I don't
want to put it damper on the
mood. You know, we're sitting
here we're having a good time
and we just start talking
about, no, that's that's not
the right kind of friends you
want. You want friends that
when you sit with them, you
remember Allah. Subhanahu wa
ta'ala and if they don't remind
you, you remind them. And
you're able to sit for hours
and hours and discuss Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and discuss
you know, the Quran and the
Sunnah. This is a gathering
that's the angels attend. He
says, number six, number six is
being good to others This is
something that will open the
heart as well. Being good to
others. What is the what is the
bare minimum of being good to
others? Treating treating them
as you'd to be treated.
What is the maximum of being
good to others? Loving for them
what you love for yourself. And
this is for the Muslims. Love
for your Muslim brother. What
you love for yourself. And of
humanity. You treat them as you
wish to be treated, right? And
this is based on their position
and and whatever the situation
is. number number seven was
valor and courage. And we
mention in depth what is meant
by courage and valor and and
it's not just in the face of
violence. That's kind of an
easy that's kind of an easy
one. Violence is not that
difficult to be courageous in.
Violence is something that is
not very difficult. It's
difficult at first. A person
usually gets very nervous at
first before they go into
battle or they go into war or
get into any altercation but
once the altercation begins,
their their focus becomes very
honed in on on the situation at
hand. However, we're speaking
about not just valor and
courage with regards to that
but courage and saying the
truth even if even if you are
accused for it, speaking up for
the truth, having the courage
to say no when no is necessary,
having the courage to say I
will, even if everybody else
will not, having the courage to
stand up, the prophet said that
the greatest jihad is and the
Sultan and Jair. The greatest
form of jihad is to say the
truth in the presence of a
tyrannical ruler. This is what
he said because you have
everything at stake at that
point. Yet you say the truth.
This is this is valor. This is
this is the courage. That will
cause Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
to guide an individual. The
eighth thing mentions is
he says the eighth thing is to
remove and to try to purge your
heart from the illnesses and
impurities that have crept
their way into your heart of
those things which are
dispraised by Allah and his
messenger and these things the
more essentially, the more, the
more impurities there are in a
person's heart the more the
person's hearts will become
confined and not be a place
that is suitable for Allah's
light and so what he's speaking
about is sins and false beliefs
and false notions and habits of
the heart that are
inappropriate and also what a
person thinks, what a person
dwells on, what a person holds
to be valuable. Some of these
things are unhealthy. Some of
these things are considered to
be an illness of the heart,
right? And so, in order for a
person to add on and to open
his heart and receive as much
to his capacity as he can of
the Quran and Sunnah and the
light of Allah, he has to clean
out his heart. And it's just
a physical body, if a
person's body is, is sweaty and
dirty, and and filthy, and then
they go and spray perfume on
it, what happened the filth on
their body corrupts the
perfume, correct? And so it
just turns into something even
worse, right? That's that's the
same kind of thing. We clear
and cleanse in order that when
the truth arrives at the heart,
it arrives at a place that is
uncorrupted, that will not
corrupt the truth in our
hearts. The ninth thing that he
mentions is
no. He says, leaving off
unnecessary things that people
do of what they look at, what
they listen to, who they who
they spend their time with,
eating, drinking, and sleep.
All of the things that are
unnecessary. He's not speaking
about what's haram. Haram is a
given. He's speaking about what
is unnecessary of these things,
right? Looking at things that
are unnecessary. That that
don't help you in your dunya or
your hereafter. They're just
extra. right? Listening to
things as well. That are and
and this now with the advent of
social media has become
extremely prevalent. You're
watching little 20, 3second
clips of silliness that if it's
not, if it's not harmful, it's
not in any way beneficial. It's
just, it's just it's just
washing away your life for no
reason. These are the things
that will cause the heart to
become, to recluse, and become
tightened. As well, those whom
you spend time with, as well
too much food, Too much
drinking. We're not speaking
about drinking alcohol. We're
speaking about drinking, you
know, just food and and and
drink. Anything that is
unnecessary. You're not
thirsty. You don't drink
anything, right? yeah, you
can have something to drink
that that tastes nice and and
you know, a cup of tea or
something. This is not what
we're speaking about. What
we're speaking about is when a
person eats too much, when a
person drinks too much and
they're constantly eating and
drinking all of the time. This
is what they do or sleeping too
much as well. He mentions. The
last thing that we're going to
mention is what we're going to
mention tonight and that is, as
he says,
This is a very important point.
And we are going to discuss it
in a way that inshallah I hope
to make practical for you.
Right? and what what I mean by
I hope to make practical for
you is I'm going to inform you
of the sources that you can get
this information from the Pure
Sources in order that you can
follow the prophet correctly.
He says the tenth thing is as
perfectly as possible following
the prophet and adorning
yourself with his attributes
and his descriptions and his
character. How he was, how he
acted, how he spoke, and so
forth and making him your true
leader and guide in your life.
You've never met him But
Alhamdulillah, Allah has
preserved his sunnah through
great men and scholars of this
Ummah has preserved his
to the point that we even know
how many gray hairs he had in
his head and how many gray
hairs he had in his beard and
what he used to wear and what
color clothing he wore. This is
how this is how closely his
life has been scrutinized and
and transmitted to us. So, the
information is there and we're
going to discuss the avenues of
of attaining that information
inshallah and making, the
prophet his ways, his
traditions, his speech, his
statements, his reactions to
certain instances or certain
things that happened always
placing that at the or the
center of your focus Always. At
every situation, you know, you
think, with the prophet be here
right now. With the prophet be
watching this right now. With
the prophet
say this right now. Would he
act this way? Would he tote
this kind of attitude?
Etcetera, etcetera. This is
this is what is meant here by
Abdul Kaim. And that is with
regards to how you worship
Allah. And what you say and
what you do and what you don't
do. As well. Because what you
choose not to do is actually is
actually counted as a deed.
Correct? It's counted as part
of your legacy. So, in things
that you refuse to do, certain
things that you do not do
because they are, they are not
something that the prophet
would condone or do or
something that he would approve
of. how do you get to know
this? That's the question here.
This is a lifelong journey,
okay? And a lot of people they
learned this, there's there's
two things that we need to
focus on, okay?
The first thing is, we want to
focus on where to get this
knowledge from, where's the
correct place to get it from?
Second, we want to focus on
we're not to get this
information from. We're we live
in a time now where information
is extremely abundant. It's so
abundant that our minds have
become numb to it and we have
become dumbed down in a way
because there's such a huge
influx of information coming at
us at every moment, every time
you turn on your phone, every
time you drive down the road,
every time you read the
newspaper, too much information
okay? And so we can't focus on
anything. recent studies
mention that in youth, around
15 years of age, and a little
older about twenty twenty-five
the average attention span is
about attention span is about
12 seconds Twelve seconds. And
why did they do these studies?
Because advertisers want to
learn how to catch you. So they
say, look, we got 12 seconds to
to reel this guy in to our
product or to our message. So,
make the first 12 seconds of
your video extremely
compelling, right? It's
pathetic. 12 seconds. Human
beings have been able to sit
and focus on one topic for 10
years and 20 years certain
people and become obsessed with
certain things whether it's the
movement of the sun or the you
geological rock formations or
or animals or or you know, the
sciences of the hearts and
theology and so forth and now,
we with the human being has
reduced himself to a creature
that has the attention span of
a goldfish. This is terrible,
right? This is this is
terrible. We're in a dark age
here of human thought. Even
though we have a lot of
information and we're all very
literate, doesn't mean that
we're knowledgeable because we
can't focus anymore. Our focus
has been broken. We get bored
easy. We get fed up easy. We
can't sit with a book because a
book doesn't jump out at us and
dance for us. It doesn't it
doesn't move on its own. I have
to actually use my mind and and
and envision things. But if you
you can regain that ability.
Right? And this is what we're
going to speak about. Number
one, what are the proper places
to get this information from?
You want to know the prophet
you want to know him as if you
know him, as if you saw him.
You want to know him that well?
There are, there are proper
ways to get this information
and there are improper ways and
sources for this information.
Proper way of this information
is through two things. Number
one, the books that concern the
biography of the prophet And
the of those books that
document the biography of the
prophet in the greatest detail
is what book Who could tell me
what book that is? Huh?
you're close. Nope. It's a book
that we all know. Huh? Say it
louder. I can't hear you. The
Quran. That's correct. Many
people overlook the Quran and
see it as separate from the
prophet's legacy. It's not.
greatest, most authentic source
of the prophet legacy and the
most detailed place is the
Quran. Because the Quran
details the direct interactions
of the prophet with Allah.
Right? Number two. Are the
books of the biography of the
prophet there are a number But
since this is an English class,
I'll mention just a couple.
Number one, the bridged version
of which is the book that we're
reading here. There's an
abridge version of authored by
Ibnil Kaim. If you can purchase
it, you can purchase it online,
right? the best the best
print that I've seen is
published by Dara Salam Riyad.
And as a as a as a rule of
thumb, anything published by
Dar Salam in Riyadh is is a
trustworthy source of
literature. Where the English
speaker, anything published by
Dara Salam is a trustworthy
source of literature.
Another
book that's more recent
and contemporary, very
prolific, very well. It's found
everywhere is a book called The
Sealed Nectar. Authored by Al
Mubarak Furi Rahima Allah. It's
a very good book. It's also
published by Dara Salam. it
came out about 40 50 years ago.
it's author has since passed
away. May Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala forgive him raises
levels and make him of those
who are the of the great
scholars of Islam who will be
in that group on the day of
resurrection. he wrote this
book
it's written very well.
there's been many many
translations of this book. He
originally wrote it in Arabic.
It's been translated since into
English. You can read Dara
Salam's print. It's okay. I say
it's okay because the
translation is a little bit
choppy and it's a little bit to
get through. It doesn't flow as
well. There are other books
that have been written. There
is a book called The Life of
Muhammad. But this book is very
well written and very eloquent.
But there are pieces of
information in it that are not
authentic and not correct.
This book the there's also a
translation of the biography of
the prophet for the great and
there's also a summarized
book of
and has the most prolific book
of the biography of the prophet
it's huge. It's usually printed
in about four four or five
volumes. But it has been
summarized and that
summarization can be found also
on by published as well. It's
okay. It's a very good book.
Anyways, we read these
different books and we put them
together, right? This is this
is a way to learn about the
prophet. The second second way
to learn about the prophet well
the third actually we mention
first the Quran second is the
biography of the prophet and
the third is the authentic
sunnah of the prophet the books
of hadith. Now, that's where we
get a little bit we get a
little bit vague. What books of
hadith should we read? Not all
narrations are authentic,
Correct? And a lot of the books
of narrations have been
translated and they should not
have been translated because
they have been grossly
misunderstood. And I'll make a
statement here. If you want to
read for instance, don't just
go and get and read it. Is an
ocean that will swallow you if
you don't know what you're
doing. It is beyond the realm
of the average layman in our
times. Don't just grab Sahih
Muslim and start reading it.
Yes, everything is authentic in
it. Inshallah, it's it's the
most authentic two books and
that's what all of these sunnah
revolves around but there are
issues and key topics that are
dealt with in a very, very,
very nuanced way that will
confuse the average reader.
These books take years of of
training and study to be able
to read properly and understand
as Imam Al Bukhari intended his
book to be understood. So, this
is why our scholars have made a
bridged versions of these
books. So, if you want read you
read the abridged version of
which was a bridge by and
that's a very prolific book.
It's called the summarized
summarized right? By by Sheikh
Alimam Zabid, Rahima Allah.
That's that's very good. That's
enough. He has in it all of the
authentic statements and and
actions of the prophet. If you
want to read Muslim, you read
the abridged, abridged version
of Sahih Muslim by Al Mundari.
this is the the version that
you will read. You will not
read the original text of Sahih
Muslim because there are chains
of narration and different
wordings and so on and so forth
that will cause confusion for a
person who doesn't know what
he's reading, doesn't know what
he Imam Muslim intended. If
you've read those two books,
you'd to move on. The best
book of Hadith to start with,
the best book of Hadith to
start with In general, Israel
took all of the books of hadith
that he had, that he had, read,
and understood, including the
six main books of hadith and
also the seventh which is Musna
[Arabic recitation]
and even in Mustaq Rajat and he
compiled the gist of the of the
prophet is almost 2000
narrations, 2 000 unique
narrations in, about 1, 800
unique narrations of the
prophet that is the book that I
would say you should place your
focus on
it's translated as gardens of
the righteous authored by read
that book from its beginning
all the way to its end and then
flip it over and read it again
and continue your life like
that and you will come to know
the prophet and and the gist of
his sunnah, right? So, these
are the three books of hadith
that I encourage a person read.
If you read a bridge version of
a bridge version of Sahih
Muslim and you've got you've
gotten the majority of the
sunnah. All it's mainly
relevant to you with regards to
the prophet Sunnah, okay? Other
books like
Malik, Muslim, etcetera. These
are for These are for people
who know how to read the books
of hadith and these takes years
for a person to learn how to
read the six books of Hadith.
In closing, we will mention the
second part and that is where
not to get this information
from. Do not get this
information off of Facebook. Do
not get this information off of
WhatsApp. Do not get this
information off of Instagram.
Do not get this information off
of. Little websites or
somewhere and some dark black
hole of the internet. As a
matter of fact, I highly
encourage that you don't even
download the apps of these
books onto your, onto your
phone and read them from your
phone. This is just my personal
opinion. You can. Is there. You
can download it right now and
read it, right? That's fine.
But we have to separate
ourselves. You need to sit with
a book. Your book react the
when you sit with the book, it
reacts differently and
interacts differently with your
brain. It's a very special
thing when a person holds a
book of paper. This is our
legacy as human beings, right?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions this legacy in the
first verses that he revealed
to the prophet don't go and and
take a a narration off of
Facebook that the who we don't
know who wrote it and then say
reported by Bukhari and then go
send it out to the whole world.
You don't know where it's from.
Anybody can write anything. Do
not, this is not a source of
knowledge, okay? As a matter of
fact, I would encourage, don't
even read it because you may be
putting into your system
something that's not correct
and not authentic and you may
you may spend years trying to
purge your heart from it. That
is enough for tonight. We'll
continue next week inshallah.
[Arabic recitation]